peta est flic pour expédier les affaires
courantes de la syrie un comité a été
composé tout est prêt pour que bachar
el-assad succède à son père la
constitution de république syrienne a
été arrangée pour qu'il en soit ainsi
reportage à damas alan chevron et
dominique bonnet comme il se doit le
parlement syrien s'est drapé d'un
gigantesque portrait de hafez el-assad
bordé de noir il s'est même quasiment
transformé en mosquée mais à l'intérieur
on fait bien de la politique exercice
inhabituel pour le président de
l'assemblée devant la presse
internationale c'est déjà rare il a dû
expliquer avec le plus grand sérieux que
la syrie est un état de droit que
l'abaissement de l'âge minimum pour
devenir président à 34 ans âge de bachar
al assad
sa promotion comme général chef des
armées etc tout cela est très normale
dans l'enceinte parlementaire
c'est encore l'autre fils bassel morts
il y a 6 ans qui figure au côté du
président du jury yens bachar n'est pas
encore idolâtré rares sont les portraits
de lui dans la ville pas de doute
néanmoins les jeux sont faits dans une
semaine dix jours maximum
il sera parfaitement élu par le
parlement vote qui sera ratifié par
référendum
vous allez voter pour lui qu'il ait
ahmed zain ministre du plan et rentrer
en syrie il ya quelques mois appelée par
bachar il est aujourd'hui l'un de ses
plus proches conseillers il est tourné
vers l'avenir
il est tourné vers l'avenir il est
conscient des défis que représente le
monde d'aujourd'hui le monde de demain
il veut savoir où va la suivre
que faire pour aider c'est le défier il
a encouragé des indices de se sortent de
ce genre j'ai été aussi amené à lui peut
pas une fois préliminaire sur les
ce que j'ai appelons les échéances
économiques de la paix un homme d'avenir
qui pense déjà à l'après guerre voilà
qui est intéressant concernant le tout
nouveau commandant en chef nommé hier de
l'armée syrienne